di quella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e dolci
ma che cazzo mi sono cappato che vivono
cascare le cose porca che c'è c'è anche
quello che volevo farlo io
e quindi c'è queste cose non posso c'è
qualcosa per caso da dire non ti sta
bene
no di melo è libero e gli adulti ragazzi
e benvenute questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog che
ragazzi una punta che lo dicevo sta
frase non va bene perché l'ho chiamato
registrato un blog che ho fatto nella
preistoria con che ragazzi la parte
della settimana è stata vinta da claudia
che ha fatto sto disegno splendido su
aver globe è tanto ragazzi adesso non ci
penso che mi viene in mente adesso così
poi passiamo direttamente alle news così
la dico subito
fatemi sapere se volete che continui a
per gap con i commenti qui sotto perché
vedo che vi piace un casino e quindi non
lo so fatemi sapere se volete ragazzi
che sapete che io gioco sempre quello
che mi chiedete di più quindi fatemi
sapere se volete credo continui perché a
me è piaciuto un casino e niente questa
era la prima news la seconda ragazzi che
importantissima siamo arrivati a 530 e
qualcosa mila iscritti già una roba
allucinante perché devo far uscire lo
speciale 500 mila iscritti ovviamente è
quindi ragazzi un casino di voi mi
stanno minacciando la mattina tipo
consigli
no il mio secondo braccio ner due non ci
sarà uno speciale ma ben due speciali
per il 500 mila iscritti ragazzi perché
volevo fare un qualcosa di diverso dal
solito perché ovviamente 500.000 essendo
mezzo milione sono un traguardo che va
celebrato in un modo un po diverso e
quindi ragazzi ho deciso di fare ben due
speciali allora il primo al quale mi
sono affezionato tantissimo perché mi
sono emozionato proprio nel farlo anche
pianto e quindi ragazzi domani al posto
di april si uscirà questo questo
speciale ed è privo inseriscono faccio
volante la settimana perché pure pure
quelle da un secolo che non lo faccio e
se tutto va bene ragazzi dovrebbe uscire
questo lunedì però dico se tutto va bene
ragazzi perché durante il week end e non
sarò a casa domani parto col col treno
variamente devo fare un viaggio quindi
dovrò editarlo durante il viaggio sarà
un pò un casino a vero di riuscirci la
mente a finirlo in tempo vanno
al massimo lo pubblico martedì comunque
insomma in sei giorni qua spero di
riuscirci comunque quindi ragazzi viene
di passare lo scarta joe dei pacchi
siccome ne ho un paio piccoli da aprile
non proprio piccoli piccoli ragazzi c'è
anche scritto fragile perché scrivono
fragile che cazzo ci vuole un treno per
rom per sta roba
direi di partire dal più piccolo perché
mi ispira tanto cercato questi ammessi
facilitazioni un casino perché sono
morbidi che voi tra l'altro non al cap
corse
pregava ci sono due braccetti zip è una
[ __ ] ce l'ho anch'io
aspettate stato saggio l'avevo già ma ne
ho altri due cioè pure rimettersi così
mi peserà talmente il braccio che devo
camminare così una penna con il mio nome
non faceva una regola favi gelli nella
descrizione c'è scritto lorenzo
tranquillo e pacato supera ogni ostacolo
tranquillissimo c'ha azzeccato in pieno
farò fuori ha realizzato a vedere il
ferito questo autunno e parler sei un
mito come si dice a napoli tu si na cosa
grande pazze mille devo fare un video in
napoletano assolutamente anche se non
sopportare un cazzo non ragazzi passiamo
al prossimo perché mica flash hanno un
titolo a caratteri cubitali fa vj non si
riconosceva giuro ormai ragazzi ma
maestria di aprire i pacchi cattorini
sarà fra i documentari tipo bear grylls
perfetto una volta sfogliata la lepre
abruzzo e un riparo per la nostra
sopravvivenza la vostra orina contiene
carboidrati utili per la vita prima o
poi ragazzi io vi giuro che ci rimangono
aprisse comunque che non c'è qua dentro
abbiamo una fan art che mi beh questa è
questa e quella che io definisco arte
poi abbiamo un
cos'è questo ei che andrebbe un po di
scienze sono io e te ho trovato in
trovato il mio stile futuristico
aspettate che
ragazze cosa è una figata aspettate e
per concludere ragazzi abbiamo un jazz
mario femmina cosa hackett maria e
quindi ragazzi si come l'hanno capito ma
che cazzo state facendo
lo capisco alla fine quando due si amano
non c'è niente da fare alla fine c'è
l'amore vince sempre con quegli anni fa
sarà il prossimo passo
ho trovato c'è una pistola e un
proiettile penso funzionino ma mi state
prendendo per il culo parte davvero come
cazzo si fa una roba tipo e khrin i
ragazzi di ripassare all'ultimo sì ma
magari se mi tolgo sti cose che non vede
un cazzo comunque sono nati che se io
quando vado in galleria da adesso mi
porto questi o lo dico e quindi ragazzi
dire vi passeranno scarpaccio del mio
carro armato ma è una è una lotta
titanica
mi spiegate che cazzo ci fanno delle
forbici per tagliare i capelli a golia
ragazzi che cazzo è sta roba
c'è per caso qualche golia in giro che
sta guardando questo video che ha
bisogno di una spuntatina di capelli
faccio 5 euro che c'è una scatola di
cerotti e poi ragazzi c'è un altro pacco
nel pacco dono a c'è chi è un caso di
cat meglio che tu bellissimo cioè io io
penso ha d'altra parte ci sono anch'io è
una cosa fantastica ma i ragazzi di
finirla con lo scalpello dei pacchi
perché volevo fare un families mondo un
po particolare stavolta sì come me lo
chiedete da tantissimo tempo di squadra
delle domande abbastanza serie che mi
fate da un'infinità di tempo la prima
domanda che quella che mi fate di più in
assoluto
come mai mi chiamo come mai mi sono
sciolto il nome fa vj visto che non
c'entra un cazzo con il mio nome o robe
del genere allora avevo detto ma tempo
fa quindi possibile che qualcuno lo
sappia quindi lo ripeto ora vj è un nome
che ho scelto un nickname che ho da
circa dieci anni quindi un'infinità di
tempo ed è un nickname che ho scelto
quando ho giocato per la prima volta
nella mia vita ad un videogioco online
che permette sarebbe ai videogiochi
online quando interagisci con altre
persone
roba futuristica che ai tempi comunque
era una roba tipo che non sapeva che
cosa volesse dire online
mi ricordo che avevo giocato a world of
warcraft videogame
abbastanza per cento e anche recente ma
è uscito dieci anni fa appunto e mezzo
che mi hanno messo a giocare ho visto un
personaggio che mi è corso incontro che
si chiamava fa vj ed ha iniziato a
scrivermi durante il gioco cioè mi ha
scritto frasi del tipo ciao come stai
come ti chiami e io ero tipo papa c'è un
computer che mi sta parlando e invece no
era una persona reale poi mi hanno
spiegato effettivamente come funzionava
sta cosa che non lo sapevo è quel
personaggio mi ricordo si chiamava fa vj
ma aveva scelto nickname
hh sobriamente aveva creato un pg così a
casa lo ha chiamato così fa vj per per
giochi fatti di quel personaggio era
durato un giorno poi non si è più visto
ed a quel punto in avanti mi aveva
talmente scosso sta cosa che ho deciso
di chiamarmi fa vj io ed è un nickname
che mi porto avanti da tipo dieci anni
quindi cazzo a 10 anni la donna e niente
questa è la bellissima storia che
racconterete poi quando sarete grandi ai
vostri figli per farli addormentare
spera non mi state addormentati voi
un'altra cosa ragazzi mi chiedete la
tantissima e che il programma uso per
ereditare vido allora io uso sono i
vega's pro 10 che è un programma che
cresce di 2 secondi quindi immaginate
quando cazzo sono contento di usarlo
guarda la webcam uso come cazzo faccio a
farla vedere che mi sto registrando con
questa è una e questa festa qui questa
bellissima una volta invece ragazzi
utilizzavo questa questa qui che vedete
questa qua che è un'amica c'è un futuro
da proiettore cazzo e poi praticamente
lo cambiate ho usato questa poi basta
per quanto riguarda invece il microfono
è uno di quelli che posso usare anche
per cantare infatti adesso vado a
sanremo come l'hanno regalato per il mio
diciottesimo compleanno tra l'altro ed
allora ho sempre usato questo poi le
cuffie sono
con chiare che ha prima di concludere
volevo fare una cazzo di cosa perché non
voglio sono troppo curioso di vedere
come funziona
ok sono leggermente inciampato in una
scatola dei ragazzi up artisti occhiali
spettacolari direi di concludere qui il
video perché sono amica non ci vedo più
vi giuro che i ragazzi di davy
concludere qui perché la camera
imposizioni devastanti se il video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche al fagiani
facebook e come ogni video tratte nella
descrizione gente se dovessi discrete di
ci vediamo al prossimo vinto e le
ragazze